welcome to
lecture number 12. i'm very sorry that
this has to be uh
uh remote i hope all of you are doing um
okay
um i know this is lots of um trouble and
stress
uh for many of you uh you know having to
move
uh not knowing necessarily where to to
move to
financial issues and so on and so forth
lots of worries about health
of your own health and others i hope
you're doing okay
[Music]
try to take good care of yourselves and
others try to look out for others
be there for each other try also make
use of mental health resources as you
can
i'll send an email about that as well
this is lecture number 12 we talk about
social preferences
so we talked about um sort of a broadly
given introduction about social
preferences
let me just move towards where we were
towards the end i showed you essentially
different ways in which you can
experimentally
elicit people's social preferences uh
using dictator games ultimatum games uh
trust games we looked at kind of like
how generous do people
behave in those kinds of games does it
look like people care about others
they're nice towards others
we then do something we sort of found
quite a bit of generosity in dictator
games and other games people seemed
quite nice
in some pieces of evidence it wasn't
quite clear whether it was like
is it that people are generally nice to
each other or is it like they don't want
to look
like a mean person either towards others
or perhaps towards themselves they want
to like think of themselves as being a
nice person
and they don't want to be mean and sort
of um
uh that might be a motivation of giving
towards others
in the games that i have shown you so
far it wasn't quite clear
um uh how to distinguish that so what
we're going to do in this lecture we're
going to look at some pieces of evidence
where there's versions of dictator and
other games
that lets us sort of look at more like
the underlying motivation of why people
give
and perhaps detect in some cases that
when people are giving in some situation
which look like people are quite nice in
fact
that might not be because they generally
care about the other person
it might be rather either because of
social image concerns this is about what
other people think about them if they
give versus not
or because of self-image concerns these
are like what do they think of
themselves
as in like you give to somebody else not
necessarily because
um you care about the other person or it
might not even be that you care about
what the other person thinks of you it's
just about you yourself
want to feel good about yourself and
therefore
you might be generous because you want
to sort of keep or maintain the image of
being a nice person
to yourself as well some of the evidence
that i'm going to show you is
you wouldn't say depressing but it's a
little bit sort of negative in a
sentence essentially what i'm going to
show you is that
people appear or in fact are uh
uh if you sort of believe that evidence
less nice than it might appear
so it says at last time at first sight
that looks like you know that's kind of
like a little depressing a little
negative in the sense that like
you know we might um uh we might be
disappointed that we thought you know
everybody was really nice and friendly
and cared so much about others maybe
that's not quite true
on the other hand however if we sort of
understand the conditions under which
people are
nice and friendly to each other and in
some ways you might sort of say well
it's not obvious that we really care
that much about whether people are
generally nice which is not what we
really care about perhaps is like how
people in fact behave
are they friendly and pro-social and
support each other and perhaps if we
understand the conditions under which
people
are nice and friendly to each other
perhaps that allows us then to think
about policies and what kinds of
how do we set up in firms or in
organizations or
in society as a whole how do we set up
policies that might make people more
pro-social overall
so this lecture we're going to talk
about more like trying to detect
different
motivations for people's pro-sociality
and then in the next lecture
um we're going to talk about now uh what
is some field evidence like so
all of what i'm going to show you for
now is essentially like mostly lab
evidence but we're going to show it some
field evidence in like real-world
situations
and companies and so on uh or field
experiments how are people behaving
and then in particular we're going to
think about some policies that might get
people to be more pro-social
versus not okay um
so we already talked about this um
as a whole so so the first thing we're
going to think about is essentially
social
recognition this is essentially social
image how do others
think about you when you give versus not
so then i'm going to show you now
several
[Music]
papers or evidence from several papers
that essentially does different
modifications mostly of the dictator
game that allows us to disentangle these
different
motivations so the first one is a very
nice paper by lazier adal that conducts
an experiment to study
mode is forgiving as sort of many
dictator games do
and they have essentially a very simple
very simple design
and two treatments one of them is a
standard dictator game this is what you
have seen before
the only difference is this one is in
euros it's sort of i think
you know done in europe uh uh think of
euros as just being the same as
as a as dollars so people can
decide to split 10 euros between
themselves and another
subject in another treatment subjects
decide
whether to even participate in the
dictator game so essentially what's
being allowed here is an exit option
you could essentially say like either
you're going to participate in the
dictator game with another person
or you could just decide you don't even
play this game
and you get just got some fixed payout
now
then if the dictator chooses to
participate
the recipient is informed of the game
and the choice of the dictator
so the recipient will be informed and
know
about there was a dictator game that was
played uh
here's the amount that the dictator
chose here's the amount that you got
um and then sort of this or sorry then
the standard dictator game commences and
then the
the the recipient just gets the money
and the recipient is essentially
informed of the action
so if you choose for example nine euros
for yourself
and one euros for the other person the
other person will know that
the one euro that they got came from a
dictator um uh
a game and there was somebody who chose
nine dollars for themselves and uh
another person
and gave like one dollars for them so
then the
one option of this or one version of
this game was essentially just like a
costless exit option that is essentially
the option where you say you
receive 10 euros without the option of
distributing the money
notice that that's exactly the same as
choosing to
opt into the game and choosing 10-0 in
terms of payouts
right if i just say i want 10 euros for
myself i give nothing to the other
person
that's exactly the same as saying you
opt out of the dictator game
the difference of course is that if you
opt out
the participant will never know that you
opted out
they will never even so the other person
will never find out that somebody was
kind of mean to them
and so you might sort of choose the
opt-out option perhaps
because you think you know the other
person will feel bad and if the other
person feels bad
uh be trying to avoid that and you might
opt out
this is kind of the exit option so the
first option here
uh the the subject line of the slides is
costly exit
in this version of the game the x is
actually not costly
it's costless to do so you can just
essentially take the ten dollars and run
and you don't have to actually
play the dictator game um now when you
think about sort of distributional
preferences
um what do distributional preference
here predict well
dictators who want to give some money
strictly
prefer to play the dictator game right
if you think you know you prefer
9-1 over 10-0 well then you're going to
play the game and say i'm going to
choose 9-1
because otherwise you just there's no
way to actually give this person money
notice sort of distributional
preferences just to remind you are
preferences where
only the outcomes matter it doesn't
matter how the outcomes come about only
the actual outcome
matter now uh there's some people who
want to just keep everything to
themselves well those people
who should just be indifferent right
they would just be like it doesn't
really matter whether i just
opt out maybe that's easier to opt out
but it doesn't really matter i would
give 10-0 anyway
either opt out or i just stay in the
game and choose 10-0
anyway but in either case the option to
exit the game
should have no effect on how much to
give dictators share
right it shouldn't matter if you want to
give some positive amount the opt-out
option it doesn't really matter because
you're not going to opt out you're going
to just opt in you stay in the game and
then just give the money to that person
and if you want to give zero anyway it
doesn't matter whether you opt out or
not you just give zero anyway and if you
opt out it's essentially effectively
giving zero to the other person
so either way you know the option to
exit should should have no effect on how
much dictators share
in particular it should not reduce how
much
dictators share does that make sense
okay the limited audience uh uh
seems to understand hope this is clear
to everybody else as well
by the way i should have said you know
the lectures now will be recorded
currently with like a very limited
audience but in general
with no audience what i'm going to do is
try to
keep sort of what i very much miss and
sort of this format is sort of the
interactive form of the lectures
so what we're going to do is try to
figure out in particular after spring
break
trying to record the lectures and then
finding some other ways of
allowing students to interact perhaps by
having a version of like well you can
watch the lectures online and then we
have sort of like essentially either
online office hours or discussions of
the slides or the particular issues that
you have
we have just some questions where we
like over zoom or other formats
we can then sort of discuss some issues
that perhaps aren't clear or you can ask
these questions and then i sort of try
to respond to that
anyway getting back to this game so
essentially we have now the comparison
between
standard dictator games and the option
of in this case
um a free exit
so in this case the exit option lowers
giving and the standard dictator game
dictators shared about like one or one
year or 87 cents
um on on average that's again sort of in
line with like the 20
25 that people tend to give in dictator
games in the very simplest form
but when you allow people to exit the
share given
uh uh goes down to 58 cents okay
and so uh that's essentially to say
there are many people who when they're
getting into the dictator game
uh they feel compelled to give at least
some money
um because you know either they feel bad
themselves somehow or they feel
that the other person will feel bad so
you kind of want to choose ten zero
but you know you feel bad that the other
or about the other person feeling bad if
you choose ten zero so you might be
inclined to choose like a two
seven three or or the like now
if you allow the costless exit option
the person who in the standard dictator
game would choose like seven three six
four or a two or the like that person
um in fact wants to choose the 10-0 but
feels bad
feels bad in the standard dictator game
so choose a seven three
once you allow the castle to costless
exit the person just chooses to ten zero
um uh and essentially then by opting out
which essentially effectively is
choosing um ten zero
now a different version of this so what
i showed you so far was
costless exit it was essentially it was
free to exit you could just choose a tan
zero and just run there was no cost of
like doing so
like there was no the pi stayed the same
there was no subtraction of that
now different versions of that were
games where like
the exit is actually costly that is to
say instead of like choosing a dictator
game where you can share
10 euros between the dictator and the
recipient
now you can choose the exit option you
have to pay essentially one euro for the
exit option so you get like nine euros
if you exit
and the other person still gets zero
okay so that's now to say
people then choose the costly exit which
is to say
they say i'd rather do the nine euros
and not play the dictator game with this
other person
rather than like playing the dictator
game where you get
10 euros potentially you could choose
like
10 euros and 0 for the other person but
they seem to be quite a few people
who choose essentially um
the costly exit the nine euros without
playing the game
and uh so they're here and say on
average subjects they're willing to take
82 percent of the pie
rather than split the full pie in the
dictator game that is to say people
essentially are willing to forego
quite a bit of money to face the
situation where you have to deal with
this other person
notice that you could choose exactly the
same you could choose 10-0 or 9-0 or the
like
people don't want to do that instead
they just do choose the costly uh
exit option so the other person never
finds out so in some ways you don't have
to deal with yourself or the other
person feeling bad about
you're not being nice right and so that
reveals in some sense saying like if you
see people
being nice in dictator games it seems to
be at least to some degree
that's not coming from people generally
wanting to be nice to the other person
and generally wanting to improve
people's payout for the sake of like
making them richer
but it's rather they want to avoid the
other person feels bad about them
or getting mad or the like now why do
let me just repeat that why do people
subject want to exit
well simply put they want to to take the
money for themselves
but they don't want to indicate to the
potential recipient that she's been
treated unfairly
so accident allows them to satisfy their
greed and not to worry about
the participant's reaction
do you have any questions
okay so that's um the first um piece of
evidence that's lazier at all on
um uh uh uncosts the exit in a dictator
game
now we discussed already last time a
little bit another version of that which
is essentially
is a different version which is like
providing excuses or covers to be
selfish
um this is a very nice paper about andre
only in bernheim where essentially the
short summary of this
is what they do is they allow for a
computer option they allow for like an
option where like essentially the
computer decides
um in some cases uh which gives people
cover um to be not nice right so if
there's a chance that you will decide
yourself
and a chance that the computer decides
and the recipient doesn't know
whether i chose or the computer decided
say it's 50
or the like i might choose like a very
mean
um a choice because you know i can
always say well you know i
i i didn't do this it was in computer i
wanted to be really nice to you
the computer happened to be just mean
sorry about that
um i really tried to be nice to you and
so people essentially use the computer
as
cover let me show you what this exact
evidence looks like so this is a
different version
of a non-anonymous dictator game so this
game is sort of set up that in a way
like you actually know who the other
person is you have to sort of face the
other person
at least in some way and so the way this
is set up is that the dictator's
choice was forced with some probability
so
um this is a dictator game with 20 euro
sorry 20 dollars um now
in the simplest version the computer
chooses 20 00 or
0 20 with equal probability okay so if
the computer chooses the computer
chooses either 20 0 or 020 with 50
chance each if it's the computer's turn
the dictator observes the allocation
chosen by the computer
the recipient does not okay if i'm the
dictator
i can see that the computer does and
then i'm sort of asked to make my choice
the recipient does not know
what the computer actually chose the
dictator then makes a dictator game
allocation with a pie of twenty dollars
such as as before just happens to be
twenty dollars rather than ten
and the computer's forced allocation
implemented with probability p
is known both to the dictator and the
recipient
so the recipient knows that the chance
of like what the chance that p
is that i'm choosing versus the computer
choosing
right so the dictator chooses with
probably the computer chooses the
probability p
the dictator chooses with probability 1
minus p
that is known to both the recipient and
to the dictator okay and now
the game essentially is set up such that
uh or
the the game will vary the probability p
so if the probability p
is like a zero if the computer never
chooses and only the dictator chooses
then we're back to the typical
dictator game then i cannot hide behind
the computer right it's obvious that i'm
choosing if i'm giving you
if i'm choosing 20 0 you know that
so like i have no way of blaming the
computer
if in contrast the probability is like
go larger than zero suppose the
probability is 50 60 70 percent
it's very likely that the computer chose
so now i can also choose 20 0
and just say well sorry like it happens
to be that the computer like implemented
this choice
i'm sorry that you got zero so i can
essentially hide behind the computer
and the larger the probability p is the
more credible is sort of this hiding
behind the computer
because you know if the chance is only
five percent or ten percent
i might you might not believe me that
the computer actually chose you're like
yeah yeah frank you know yeah you you're
telling me the computer really was you
but if the chance is like 90 or the like
then it's actually very likely that the
computer very
plausible that the computer chose the
main outcome um
and then i might sort of also just
choose the main outcome because you're
never going to find out you know if you
suspect that this is me as opposed to
the computer
um and then at the end you know the
recipient
only learns the allocation um not the
dictator's choice right the the
recipient only learns what they get they
do not learn like
what i chose or whether it was the
computer or me who who chose
they only know the probability p with
which like
uh the computer i made that uh choice
yeah
uh does the dictator know
um yes yes so the dictator knows
the dictator exactly the dictator knows
p um the dictator even knows i think the
the the actual choice that's uh the
computer made yeah
that's uh but that's that's key uh here
so the dictator knows
both the dictator and the recipient no p
that's really important
because only if i know what p is i can
actually react to it and hide
so the prediction here will be that if p
is very high if the computer chooses a
high probability
people will be more likely to be mean uh
in the 200 case because you know i can
just essentially emulate the computer
and hide behind it but for that i need
to know exactly what
what p is so now what do distributional
preferences here predict again
distributional preferences are
preferences such that you only care
about the outcome
you don't care about what uh how this
came about
so the dictator here should only think
about the case in which her choice
counts
that is to say the computer is entirely
irrelevant because i can't influence
what the computer does anyway it doesn't
matter whether the computer chooses with
five percent or 10
or 20 chance or 50 or even 70 chance
the only thing i should care about is
like well for the chance of one minus p
when i choose myself
what am i going to do and what are my
distributional preferences how much do i
want to give you versus the other person
and that's essentially the only case in
which she can in fact
affect the distribution and so p should
have essentially no effect in people's
choices okay so that's a very
straightforward prediction
essentially you only care about the case
when you can make a difference
and in that case you just choose
whatever you want to choose between
20 uh 0 and 0 20 whatever like you want
to sort of to
give the other person the other cases
are just irrelevant because they are out
of the person's
control now why might p matter anyway i
already said that
essentially p might matter because you
can hide behind the computer
if p is particularly high yes
so the recipient knows that the computer
can only choose
20 or zero um yeah there's different
versions of that exactly
so and exactly since in some cases
the computer could choose 20 00 or 0020
with equal probability
so the recipient knows that that's not
if it's not
if it's like 80 20.
exactly that's exactly right i'm going
to show you exactly that evidence
in fact what the game will do is um
sorry the question was like does the
recipient know whether it's 20 00 versus
18 2 or something else
and that's exactly right the only
plausible way in which i can hide behind
the computer in this case is if i want
to be selfish it's twenty zero
right if i choose nineteen one you know
it was me it can't up in the computer
because the computer can only do twenty
zero
zero twenty right and that's key here
and there's gonna be some variation and
that variation will really what the
computer does
and essentially that will exactly reveal
people's hiding behind the computer
because in some variation it will be the
computer that's 19 1
and suddenly people choose a lot of 19.1
right and the only reason why you might
do that is exactly because you might
want to hide behind the computer
so let me show you that exactly that in
fact so um
uh here's now what we find this is a bit
of a complicated graph so let me try to
walk you through that
in detail so um the graph shows you the
following it shows you on the y-axis
axis the fraction that people gave on
average for the different scenarios
so like how much what percentage of the
20 uh dollars
did the person give to the other person
decide the dictator to do
this is not the computer so this is only
the dictator's choices
um on the x-axis we see the probability
of the force choice
um of x zero uh
being zero that's to say like um
this is essentially to say what is the
fourth choice what is the chance that
the other person gets
zero okay what is the so the pro the
computer chooses with some probability
twenty zero so 20 for the dictator and
zero for the other person
and that's happening for different
probability so the probability is either
zero
twenty-five percent fifty percent or uh
seventy-five percent that's the p
that i mentioned earlier let's look at
like zero percent
p equals zero percent to start with
that's essentially the scenario
in which the computer is irrelevant the
computer never makes any choices
what you see essentially is um the
typical sort of behavior in dictator
games
uh sorry i should have also mentioned
then like here's like how much then the
the different lines are like
how much is given to the other person
right so the blue line that you see
there is like
10 so that's the 10 10 allocation how
much is a dictator given to the other
person
um the red line is a zero uh this is
essentially the twenty zero allocation
and the other two lines down there are
like um uh
one two to nine and there's also larger
than ten
okay what we're going to focus on is
essentially how often does the person
give zero
and how often does the person give like
50
so when you look at the zero percent
line essentially that's the typical
dictator choice again
p is zero the computer is entirely
irrelevant the computer can't do
anything
now i cannot hide behind the computer we
get sort of the typical dictator
game outcomes which is like you know 55
percent of people actually more than
usual
give a half they choose a 10 10
allocation
um about 30 of people choose zero that's
very common
and then there's some people below that
give like either you know two to nine or
uh one or even larger than ten so that's
typically what we see
in a in a dictator game now moving to
the right is now
probably a positive piece this is p
equals point
uh 25 50 75
okay and now what we're seeing
essentially is that as you move to the
right in particular
going from zero to 25 and from 25 to 50
the probability of or the the fraction
of people who choose zero for the other
person
goes up by quite a bit right so now for
example look at the 50
chance peak was 50 percent now there's a
50
chance that the other person gets zero
anyway because the computer chose so
and now if i'm the dictator essentially
i
i i can also choose 20 0
and you know once you as a recipient see
the outcome you cannot tell
the 50 of us a 50 chance that that was
me it was a 50
chance it was like the computer uh uh uh
choosing that
and so in that case um uh you see now
that 70
of people actually choose twenty zero so
that fraction goes up from thirty
percent
uh for p equals zero to like about fifty
percent for p equals twenty five percent
and to seventy percent for p equals
fifty percent
so essentially the larger p is at least
for the range of zero to fifty percent
the larger is the fraction of people who
actually choose the twenty zero
allocation
presumably because it's now more
plausible if i'm hiding behind the
computer
okay now you see for p equals 75 percent
now there seems to be sort of like uh no
increase anymore
uh this is a little unclear how to
interpret that it could be so
to some degree this could be because um
you know now 50
is already large enough it's already
very plausible that the computer chose
anyway so going from 50 to 75 there's no
additional benefits of hiding behind the
computer
it could also be that people in some way
sort of like feel bad for the other
person because there's a high chance
that they get zero
anyway from the computers you might as
well give something
to that other person um perhaps i'm not
quite sure but that's in some sense not
the point here
the point here is that the fraction who
are mean goes up by a lot when you can
hide behind the computer
the fraction who looks or is quite nice
who chooses the 10 10
allocation goes down by quite a bit does
that make sense and a few in the
following slides i've sort of
added a fairly detailed description of
this but um uh
just pause you for a second to see
whether that makes sense
okay so i think i have already said all
of this this is to say
the higher p star p is the higher the
easier is for the dictator to hide
behind the computer
um i said all of that already so when
you sort of take together this evidence
um uh uh it sort of seems to be evidence
that people are not as nice
um uh uh as results from sick title
single
uh simple dictator games might suggest
because in some sense
uh in the simple dictator games they
would like to do something else but they
just can't really
do so um here's and this is kind of like
your question here
um this is like a very nice variation
that they have
this is a different variation where the
computer now chooses nineteen one with
probability p
okay so the computer essentially chooses
nineteen for the dictator and one for
the other person
with probability again p equals zero
twenty-five percent fifty percent
uh uh seventy-five percent and exactly
as you sort of predicted and
thought about is like you see the same
thing happening for the people choosing
10 that fraction goes down
but instead people are not now choosing
more of 20 0 and said what they're
choosing in fact this fraction of people
who choose 20 zero the red line goes
down a bit instead what goes up is the
19 1 allocation so lots of people now
choose
19 for themselves and one for the other
person well why is that
it's because now you can hide between
the 91 choice of the computer right and
sort of
that's the selfish choice the 20-0
choice in fact goes down a little bit
because again
perhaps because it becomes quite obvious
that um so these are people who are
quite selfish anyway um but now they
choose the 191 option to switch to 191
because now you're kind of like mean
anyway but now you can essentially hide
behind the computer
okay any questions on this
okay so now what's going on here so um
uh uh so one potential explanation is
face saving concerns
essentially a social image so this is
the motivation to avoid
unfavorable judgment by others this is
essentially if you care about what
others think about you you might
do engage in certain behaviors so
the experiment provides a way to provide
people to avoid such judgments right so
this is a remember this is non-anonymous
game you have to sort of face this other
person and sort of deal with them
afterwards at least in some way
so now essentially the experiment the
computer provides essentially
people an opportunity to save face um
and essentially to
to to keep up their social image right
because essentially what you're trying
to avoid here is like if you choose a
20-0 option
the other person will kind of think
you're not very nice and that's you know
either
either you're trying to avoid to have to
see that they're unhappy
you might just feel bad about them if
they're unhappy or you know
perhaps more plausible it just feels bad
for you if other people think you're
kind of mean so you're kind of like you
want to be mean but you don't want
others to think you're mean and
therefore you hide behind the computer
um this is i think i said all of this
already so
both of these types of evidence i think
the the the the the exit in the dictator
game
but also the um uh the the evidence that
i showed you just now hiding behind the
computer seems to sort of say
when there's an option um uh to avoid um
um
uh sort of the people feeling bad or
people
are feeling uh that you mean to them
people tend to take that option and then
essentially
that reduces their giving behavior um
now
in some sense when you think about like
many other uh and there's some empirical
evidence on this by gautam rao and
stephanie lavinia uh
ricky marmandy and and and others
people in uh situation when it comes to
voting or in other sort of
gift giving and uh uh choices overall is
people tend to um
[Music]
are willing to pay essentially to avoid
situations where they're asked to give
right this is like somebody comes to
your door and says would you like to
donate for this cause or would you like
to
uh vote for this candidate and so on and
so forth
uh you know people might once they asked
they might say yeah sure i'll do it
uh because they feel bad it feels like
it's not a very social limit he shows
you pictures of
of of of poor children um in
in in some terrible situations
if you sort of now say no i don't want
to give any money you look like a really
mean person
so what people then tend to do is they
tend to essentially just avoid the
situation altogether
by either pretending that they're not
home or indicated never opening the door
or you know if you see somebody on the
street who wants to like
uh uh collect donations you might just
essentially avoid that person altogether
go out of your way
if she's if you see a beggar on the
street you essentially might sort of go
around that person
because you know you try to not avoid
you try to avoid essentially judgment
either feeling bad for them about you
being mean to them or
feeling bad about them just judging you
in certain ways for not being a nice
person
okay how do we think about this in terms
of utility function
we're not going to talk about this very
much we're going to get at this a little
bit
back about this when you talk about like
beliefs
and belief based utility but just to
give you a sense of how to think about
this in terms of like modeling it
so what you need essentially is like
another term and utility function
in addition to your distributional
preferences about like you put some
weight on how much you get and how much
the other person gets
you need some other term i called it
like v which is like player once
believed about row like how much what
does the other person think that your
row is
right so if you really don't want to
give anything to that other person
you kind of want to avoid that the other
person thinks that um
you put very little weight on on the
other person so row again to remind you
is the weight that's put on the other
person
this is the perspective of player two so
row is like the weight that you put on
the other person
and now essentially um player two might
put some weight on player one in terms
of like the output that they get they
want to give them some money and if they
have more money they feel happier
um but they also put some weight on what
player one
thinks that my row is so right so if i
have the choice do i want to give 10 uh
uh
if i have 10 dollars and i can choose
that in a dictator game to give it to
the other person
uh i might want to do 10-0 but i might
also
and that's essentially just coming from
my row but i also kind of don't want the
other person to think that my row is
zero
right so i might derive you positive
utility from the other player
thinking that my row is like whatever
0.3 or 0.5 or whatever
um i like that the other person thinks
that i'm of a positive
weight on them and therefore i might
give them more more generally i guess
you can just sort of have a utility
function
that depends on the other person's
outputs or
the the uh or each person's
outcome like how much they get and on
the other's beliefs about what my
utility function looks like so
essentially people care about
whether others think that they are nice
or have a
concerns for others in the utility
function okay we'll again we're not
going to talk about this in in more
detail at least for now
we're going to get back to this when we
think about beliefs and belief-based
utility
which essentially is the idea that
beliefs are
potentially instrument not just
instrumental but so beliefs
about like others usually help you make
good decisions
but it might be that you also just
derive utility from beliefs you might
drive utilities from thinking that
you're smart good looking uh
and so on okay any questions on
on this
okay so now um
one question you might have and i
already alluded to that is like are
people
giving because they enjoy giving or
because it's uncomfortable refusing to
give right is it like
i really want to give and i feel really
good about it i get some warm glow in
some ways
or is it in some ways like i'm giving
not because i actually enjoy it
and i i i'm happy about it but rather
because otherwise i just feel
um i feel bad and um uncomfortable
so the evidence we talked about suggests
that the latter motivation
is more important for many so many
people kind of like just feel bad
by not giving um uh this is essentially
particularly
the evidence that people are willing to
pay to avoid dictator games
um uh uh that i showed you there's a
very nice
paper about um what's called moral
wiggle room
which is the idea that like uh and gets
at the idea that like
in a way if people opt out of the
dictator game they have to sort of
justify
to themselves that they're mean right so
if you have like self-image if you also
care about like
how do you think about yourself are you
a good person or not
uh how do you justify to yourself
essentially that you chose the 20-0
option and tadana at all paper is a very
nice paper that sort of illustrates that
very nicely
so um this is again a very simple
game subject are asked to choose between
um
a self other so how much do you get
yourself and how much does the other
person get
uh there's two options here option a is
you get six dollars for yourself
and x dollars for the other person
option b is you get five dollars for
yourself
and y dollars for the other person and x
and y
is varied across um subject and
randomized
so you one option here is like x
equals 1 and y equals 5. now what does
that mean for options a and b
that means like option a is like if you
had to choose would be six for yourself
and one for the other person
option b is like five for uh
each player okay so now choosing between
option b
and option a if you choose option a
essentially you get one dollar more
than you would get if you chose option b
but the other person gets like four
dollars
less than they would get if you chose
option b so choosing option a is not a
particularly nice
option essentially you you you decide
that like one additional dollar for you
is worth more than uh four dollars that
the other person
um gets less okay and
so again that's not a very nice move so
you know um
most people in fact tend to choose
option b
okay when faced with that direct choice
that is to say
26 percent of people choose option a
they choose sort of like the selfish
option if you want
and 72 if 74 percent choose option b
which is sort of like in some way the
nice thing
to do this is a very standard version of
it there's no other
things going on there's no exit option
and so on and
so um you know the person again i said
all this um
uh uh so now when people choose option b
there's essentially two explanations
here one is like the person is kind of
quite nice the other person explanation
is like in some ways they're not that
nice but they're just trying to avoid
feeling bad about
um they kind of want to choose option a
but you know if you choose option a you
feel kind of really bad about it and
that's why you don't do it
now the game also has a twist here which
is like for some other subjects
like these are like some subjects just
had this on this choice only
they choose as i said 74 percent chose
option b
some other subjects um x and y were
initially unknown
with either x equals 1 and y equals 5
or x equals 5 and y equals 1
and those are implemented with 50 chance
okay so initially you don't know it
could be either
let me just write this down it could be
one of two scenarios both
are have the chance 50 so one of them is
like if you choose option a that's the
choice that we just had before like the
first one is option a versus b
that's what we just had which
essentially is six one versus five five
so there choosing a is a pretty selfish
move
that's the option i just showed you the
second scenario is
it's a six five versus five one
now it's unambiguously clear that you
should choose option a
right because the other person you're
better off the other person is better
off everybody is happy
so surely you should choose option a
essentially option a
dominates option b in the second
scenario
okay now
here's the twist subjects could
costlessly find out
which one is the case um and the
the recipient in this case will not
learn what the other person did the
recipient just essentially receives the
money
okay the the shipment does not know what
the person does
so now um essentially i would tell you
um there's two scenarios going on
either one or two i'm going to ask you
to choose
a versus b and you have two options
before that choice
the option is either you can just choose
without not knowing which scenario
you're in
or you can choose costlessly to find out
whether you're in choice one versus
choice b
sorry and choice one versus choice two
okay
so so is it set up clear
i'm happy to repeat yeah
so if you're in the game there's a 50
chance that you're in scenario one and a
50
chance in scenario two that is fixed
okay you have two choices uh to make in
your and your whole decision
the first one is do you want to find out
whether you're in scenario one or in
scenario two
so either you don't find out it's just a
fifty percent chance of scenario one and
fifty percent chance of scenario two or
you find out
causelessly i'm gonna tell you you're in
scenario one or scenario two
it's already decided which scenario
you're in you just don't know it
okay so your first choice is you want to
know which scenario you're in
the second choice then is like between a
and b
and you either choose without knowing
what's an area you're in usually either
in one or two you choose for a and b and
then it's just going to be implemented
afterwards like
the a or b for each of the scenarios or
like the one that's actually implemented
uh or you know already you're in
scenario one or scenario two
because you've costly found out and then
you make that choice
about a and b does it make sense okay
perfect
so now first we can think about like
distributional preferences
what happens if you just have purely
distributional preferences
could this additional twist in any way
lower people's giving behavior
and so when you are distributional
preferences notice that um what i added
to you so what i'll be comparing here is
like
only having the first scenario to choose
we're comparing that
to the twist so i'm comparing
essentially this scenario this is like
the people who chose
without having um this is the people who
chose without having like this
additional twist going on
we're gonna compare those kinds of
people to people who are randomized to
have this additional twist
where they first have to like the the
choice or the option to costlessly find
out where they're in
and the question i'm going to ask is
like now can it be or how does adding
this additional option affect people's
giving behavior
in particular is it possible that people
give less because of adding this
this additional choice so now there's
sort of two options um overall
either it's the case that your optimal
choice depends on x and y
right so either you're going to tell me
like well
whether i choose a or b it depends on x
and y
and if that's the case well of course
then you want to find out what a
x and y is remember what is x and y x
and y is the thing that i have at the
top
x and y is either x equal 1 and y equals
5
or it is x equals 5 and y equals 1.
so it either is the case that it matters
to you what x and y are
either you really want to find out what
x and y is well in that case surely if i
asked you do you want to costly find out
you do want to find out because you want
to make the right choice right you want
to know am i in scenario one or am i in
scenario
two so then you know if i offer you the
costless
option to find out which choice you're a
missionary you're in
but you're gonna want to find out and
then and you find out that you're in the
x equals one and y equals five situation
you should make the same choice that you
chose previously
right if if it if you chose previously
option a or option b once you find out
what scenario you're in surely you're
going to choose the same thing because
you only care about distribution
preferences you're going to just choose
the same thing
okay now if your choice on the other
hand does not depend on x and y
you should be indifferent between
finding out or not and you know
either and you know it shouldn't really
matter whether i give you that option in
some sense you should choose the same
thing as you chose before
in either case when x equals 1 and y
equals 5
leaving x and y initially unknown so
adding this additional option
should not decrease the amount of giving
if anything you should sort of
anyway it should not should not affect
it in any case
but in particular it should not decrease
it
so let me show i'll have you look at
this for a second just be clear on that
so essentially what i'm saying is like
adding this additional thing
the scenario two either the scenarios
matter
and if the scenarios matter whether
you're in scenario one versus scenario
two if you make different choices
well then surely you should find out
which scenario you're in
and you're gonna say okay i really to
know once you know whether you're in
scenario one
suppose you're actually in scenario one
you're gonna should make the same choice
as you did before
right and
if you say well i actually don't care
which scenario and i'm going to make the
same choice anyway
then adding this additional scenario
shouldn't really matter anyway because
you choose the same thing
anyway but regardless adding essentially
this scenario too should not decrease
how much you
give now what they find instead is like
44 chose not to find out x and y
and of these subjects 95 so it shows
option a
okay so these are people who essentially
they say i'd rather not know what's
going on here
and and and then they chose option a
which is either the fairly selfish
option or it's the option that's better
for both people let me go back to this
to see this
so when when given these two choices
they essentially say i'd rather not know
even if it's costless to do i don't want
to know whether i'm scenario one or two
i'm gonna choose option a why do they do
that or what what do they what's going
on in their minds
yes
exactly so if you so
if you find out whether it's scenario
one or scenario two two things can
happen
one will be like you'll be in scenario
number two
you're gonna choose option a because you
know that's better for everybody
or you're gonna be in scenario one well
then choosing a is kind of really like a
selfish or mean move
and then once you do that then you have
to sort of deal with like well am i like
a mean person or not
instead what people do or seem to do is
like they just say i actually don't want
to find out i
i it could be either way you know who
knows what's going on
could be scenario one could be scenario
two who knows
and but you know there's a good chance
50 chance that it's a scenario two
in which case you know choosing option a
is actually good for everybody
so let me just not find out and then
choose option a
and i'm going to essentially make myself
think that like oh you know probably it
was like
scenario number two right so essentially
what people are doing here
is they sort of delude themselves in
some way into thinking
um that they're doing the right thing or
they're doing like not a mean thing
by avoiding information that would
essentially be
uh free right so if you really wanted to
find out whether you're mean or not
you could just get the information and
sometimes it's like free they're
entirely available
instead what people do is they just say
oh i'd rather not know
and then they choose a thing that's at
least potentially
a mean and so then not only is it the
case that
44 of people choose not to find out
but also the fraction of selfish people
goes up by
a lot okay there's lots of so what i'm
so i showed you this is a little bit
tricky but essentially
what i showed you here is that there's a
50
chance to be in scenario one versus in
scenario two
okay and the 63 percent that i'm going
to show you here
like this is the fraction who
essentially chose to selfish choice this
is only looking at the 50
uh chance of like for which um uh x
equals one and y equals five
so essentially this is taking like the
half of the uh
uh the the
the cases in which actually uh x equals
one and y equals five was implemented
these are cases where either the person
found out or not
uh but when you take those things
together so these are like essentially
two scenarios or two sort of the the sum
of two things that happen
uh one is the person didn't find out and
chose option a or b
or the person actually found out but
taking together essentially 63 percent
of people
in those cases chose the selfish option
option a
compared to like the 26 and the baseline
case that i showed you earlier
so putting these things together
essentially means that there's quite a
few people
who uh conveniently don't want to find
out whether they mean or not
they choose then the mean option um and
much more so than when they don't have
this whole uh
uh uh what's your called like moral
wiggle room which essentially sort of
the option to delude themselves in like
they're actually not that mean because
you know probably it was like
it was better for everybody to choose
option a does that make sense
so now you might ask like two things
well
it could be that this is concerned about
others beliefs this could be about
social limit or it could be about
self-image
now the experiment is precisely set up
in a way that in fact it's not about
social image the other person in fact
doesn't
doesn't um uh find out whether you
learned her payoff
um and so the other person actually so
so not learning doesn't really help
improve her the other person only sees
the result
so whether i actually learn about like
which scenario we're in
doesn't really actually help improving
the other
person's opinion the only person who
actually knows whether you found out
what scenario in
is actually you yourself when you make
that choice which really suggests that
this is about
saving face about self-image people
essentially want to delude themselves or
make themselves think that they're nicer
than they actually are
by avoiding information that could
actually
help them make the right choice or be
nicer if they really wanted to be
right so and if you really want it to be
nice what you would do is you would
really find out
which scenario you're in you would
choose option a and scenario two when
it's better for everybody and you choose
option b if it's
better for the other person or really
costly for the other person to choose
option a
so let me sort of summarize here so the
most
likely explanation is that how dictators
it's really based on how dictators feel
about themselves so the uncertainty in
whether the selfish action helps or
hurts the other person gives an excuse
to be selfish
right so now i can say oh you know 50
chance that this is the right choice for
everybody
so that's an excuse so you can sort of
keep telling yourself that you didn't
um mean any harm like i really don't
know what you mean i thought you know
with a good chance the other person will
be better off as well
um and so many
so what this is sort of the this term is
sort of called moral wiggle room which
essentially is sort of like
helping you would be in like an
ambiguous situation
because once you haven't found out it's
actually unclear whether the other
person
is better off or worse off by choosing
option a and b the experiment
is set up in a way that like if you do
not find out which scenario you're in
it's not clear what's better for the
other person what to choose
um but of course that's amazing in some
sense because like
you could always like find out
costlessly and sometimes you can just
delude yourself and say ah it's not
clear like what should we do
i i don't know could be good for the
person bad for the person or whatever
but i'm choosing a
but of course that's like silly because
in some sense that's not an explanation
that
the folds of water because you could
always find out if you really wanted to
know whether you wanted to be nice to
the other
person it's very easy to find out what's
going on so that's essentially to say
people want to save face in front of
themselves
as opposed to in front of others
any questions on this
okay so now a different version of that
is giving and communication which is
again sort of in some ways like
about social image concerns about like
uh having to deal with others reactions
to you
this could be about self-image or social
image but either way it's about sort of
like some form of communication how
others or you yourself feel
so um ellingson and um johannesson
modified the dictator again by allowing
for a very limited form of communication
um one group of subject played the usual
dictator game which is just like as
usual
um in the other group the recipients
only were allowed to send anonymous
messages to the dictator after receiving
their share
is that the version you played or was it
different for you could you already talk
to them earlier
when there was communication
it might have been the exact version
that you played or it might have been
like in your version you could actually
talk to the other person earlier i'm
actually not
the only message before
you decided i see so that's a different
a slightly different version from what
you played
uh this one is a version where um the
recipient could only respond so the
dictator
gets the ten dollars or whatever people
has played the dictator makes a choice
and then the recipient can like
essentially send a message back
uh can in some way sort of reciprocate
if you want could be like a nice message
if you give like
um quite a bit of money or it could be a
mean message
um if you didn't give a lot of money and
anticipating that might affect the
dictator's
choices and so this is kind of um
what what what they found in the in the
paper so essentially um
the anticipation of feedback increased
sharing from 25 percent to
34 in this specific game that's quite a
bit
so um most um recipients in fact
do choose to to send a message um the
messages vary
quite a bit so it's about like you know
very mean messages saying like you know
uh so you chose uh to take all the money
yourself you greedy bastard
i was just wondering if there was anyone
who would do that and the answer is
apparently yes apparently people like
you exist have a nice evening
so that's not a very nice message i also
censored a few messages that were in
there earlier
another one is thank you greedy bastard
you will
like it as investment banker hope you
will buy something nice
um and then there's sort of positive
message presumably when people actually
given quite a bit of money which is like
you know there's hope for a better world
with the help of your generosity and
your big heart i can tonight
break the black pudding occurs no more
pea soup
you have a standing invitation to dinner
at my place the door is always open with
love
so you know that varies by quite a bit
and sort of anticipating those kinds of
messages
you can see how dictators then might
sort of um in particular if they play
this repeatedly and have some experience
with it
um might opt into like um giving more
um so this indicates that sort of beyond
caring about the recipient's reaction
dictators um uh uh care how shielded
they are from it
so it's not just about like you might
feel bad so what i showed you previously
in the cost of
exit thing it was more about like i'm
worried about you feeling bad
and i don't want you to feel bad even if
i don't have to face you in any
situations
this one is about like i might worry
about you feeling bad but i also might
worry about like
um so i might worry about like
receiving that message from you so
there's some people who might actually
be fine about the other person feeling
bad as long as i don't have to like face
it
uh but now if i actually have to face
the message from the other person
i might you know be behaved nicer in
some ways
um uh because i didn't have to actually
deal with the fact or like
face the fact that uh uh perhaps i'm not
a nice person
in our um version i looked this up it
seems like there's essentially no
not much evidence of like communication
affecting behavior
this could be perhaps because the
version with communication was different
from
uh what was played here so it doesn't
seem like once the person gave i think
the game was just over
as opposed to like once the person gave
um uh you could sort of
send a message back and sort of
reciprocate in some uh
some way so this is uh here you can see
that in the dictator game without
communication
this is um notice that the axes are
changing a little bit this is like the
monetary stakes no communication this is
with communication notice that the
access changes i can't really fix this
from the software but if you look at the
average offer
uh with no communication is 38
percent with communication that's 37 so
if anything is a little bit lower
the comparison is a little bit unclean
because it's like over time you know
maybe later in the game you played
different than earlier in the game it's
not quite
cleanly randomized but it doesn't seem
like in your case like the communication
mattered very much
again perhaps that's because the the
nature of the game is somewhat different
for the um
sorry this is actually not the dictator
again this is the um this is the
ultimatum game uh for the uh this is a
typo at the top
for the ultimatum game it seems like um
uh the communication matters a little
bit when you look at this when you look
at the very left
people giving zero uh for whatever
reason i don't know how
you communicated and what you said but
it seems like your communication made
people more likely to group zero and
then these
zero options being rejected so this is
what you see on the very left is in the
ultimatum game
the red red is essentially these are
offers that are rejected
without communication nobody was giving
zero
with communication somehow people are
giving zero and then these offers were
rejected
so perhaps some of you gave like very
negative messages or threats or whatever
and that really sort of pissed off the
dictator the other person and then
essentially that sort of really
backfired
so i don't know who is teaching you how
to communicate um but maybe you want to
think about this
uh in future games somehow communication
if anything that made things worse uh
compared to the no communication case
but even there if you look at sort of
like the the
um the average offer is like forty seven
percent on the uh this year on the top
and uh uh again forty six six percent
um with communication so it doesn't make
a huge difference
either way okay
any questions on that
okay so then i'll we going to talk a
little bit about intentions based uh
social preferences let me tell you sort
of like a
um a brief um a tale about this
that sort of illustrates this point
quite nicely so a boy finds two ripe
apples as he walks home from school
he keeps the larger one gives a smaller
one
to his friend the friend says
it was nice to keep the larger one
the boy says well what would you have
done and the friend says
i'd i'd have given you the larger one
and kept the smaller one
well and the boy says well we each got
what we what you wanted so what are you
complaining about
right and so what does that illustrate
it illustrates that
it's not uh always about like outcomes
or like the distribution even of
outcomes or the like
what seems to matter is like um
sort of some form of like justice or
fairness in how the allocation came
about
right and and most of economics
essentially uh we assume that our
satisfaction of outcomes like how much
we like sort of certain outcomes and so
on when you look at people's utility
function
often essentially it's outcome based
what matters is essentially how much you
consume and so on
so the satisfaction with outcomes
doesn't depend on how the outcome came
about
and here when uh when you look at these
apples how the apples are distributed
the larger the the friend actually
doesn't seem to care that much about
whether he gets the larger or the
smaller apple
what the friends cares about is like is
your other friend a nice person or is
the allocation of the outcome fair in a
sense of like
didn't he just keep the larger apple
because he could and then sort of was
like mean to to his friend
so really what seems to matter quite a
bit is um
there's quite a bit of work in
organizational behavior and economics
and social psychology is the idea of
procedural justice
fairness in the process used to allocate
resources seems to matter
um quite a bit so maybe like another way
to put this it's kind of okay actually
for most people if some people are
richer than others that's fine
but it's much less okay so if if the
obtained money is coming in some corrupt
uh a process or you know if it's just
kind of like
unfair because some person was born
really rich and you know uh the other
person was born really poor
and there's not of no mobility or
opportunity
um uh in society that's sort of relating
to the idea that like
in a way the american dream is that like
everybody can become rich and that's
essentially the key here and then if
some people are richer than others
people often think that's okay
what's not okay however is like if some
people have vastly different
opportunities or chances than others
or if there's lots of corruption where
essentially some people get certain jobs
not because you know they're qualified
but rather because their parents or
their family or their friends or
whatever
are very powerful or they have corrupted
others in other ways
okay now
there's a question of fairness and then
there's a question of
reciprocity uh which is essentially the
idea that
people so fairness people have
preferences for fairness they like fair
outcomes more than others
unfair outcomes another form of that is
reciprocity is like
people like to treat others as others
have treated or
treating them
more generally the way we treat others
essentially depends on the way they
treat us
right so like if somebody's mean to you
you're going to mean to them if
somebody's nice to you you're going to
be nice to them
and that's a really important motivation
a lot of behavior
now um this gets us back to the
ultimatum game
i'm going to talk about this only very
briefly which is um
the question of like why do responders
uh reject low efforts in the ultimatum
game we talked about this a little bit
you can think about distributional
preferences
we talked about the chinese and raven
and
about the preferences about being behind
versus not there's an explanation that's
based on distributional preference where
you just don't want to be really behind
and therefore you reject the
unfair offers but another one is like
you think you're really treated unfairly
and you're willing to punish the
proposer for such unfairness and
in like a simple ultimatum game you
can't really tell whether it's
hypothesis one or two
but um and we talked about about this
already
you can compare responders choices in
the ultimatum game the choice is when
the offer isn't generated by the
by the uh by the other person the
recipient or like the
sorry the the other person for example
you can look at like
um uh choices that was that were
generated by the
computer by like a third person and so
on so if it's
um generated by the third person you
might say like i shouldn't punish the
other person
uh in the game because you know it's not
that person who chose it it's some other
person so it's not their fault so why
should i punish them
similarly if the computer chose again if
i have less than the other person that
might be okay
i might not be happy about it but it's
not the other person's fault it's the
computer
who chose in the next lecture we're
going to talk about sort of a field
application of that it's a very nice
paper by emily braza and co-authored
a co-author which is about uh the morale
effects of pay and equality
this is about how workers behave in a in
a work environment
when people are paid unequally and
the the short summary of this paper is
that when workers this is a field
experiment in india when workers are
paid unequally
they might they might
be really unhappy and be less productive
at their work because essentially
they're in particular if they have to
collaborate with other workers who are
paid more than them
but in particular what they seem to care
about is like is this
fair that the other person earns more so
if you earn more than i do
it might actually be okay if i can
understand that you are much smarter
faster or better at what you do so if in
some observable ways i can tell that
you're better than i am
then in some sense i might be perfectly
fine with you earning like 10
20 50 or whatever percent more money
because i know you're a better worker so
okay fine you're paid more
that seems to kind of that seems like
fine and okay
however in some other situation where
it's kind of not that obvious whereas
like it looks like you're doing the same
thing that i'm doing and not really
faster or better
and so on yet you're paid more i might
be really like annoyed and unhappy about
it
um and you might also be uncomfortable
because you feel bad about being paid
more than i
i do for doing exactly the same thing so
the
experiment by emily braza and co-authors
is doing exactly that looking at sort of
situations where workers are paid
unequally versus the same and situations
where
this is like justified versus not and
really seems to be that fairness matters
well perceived fairness matters quite a
bit for these workers
when workers can justify being paid less
uh
in some way or more than others that's
okay when it's unjustified they really
get annoyed
uh and produce a lot less in that
particular setting
okay so let me now start with like some
field evidence we're going to talk a lot
more about field evidence next time let
me briefly talk about this paper here
and then next time i'm going to talk to
tell you a lot more about that
so this is a very nice paper by bandier
idaho which looks at the impact of
relative pay versus piece rates
uh uh on productivity piece rates is
just like whatever you produce you're
gonna pay
be paid by unit of your output you can
just get some fixed
payment per each unit of output that you
produce
relative pay is essentially your workers
are paid relative to others
so if i'm working like 50 more than you
do i get a lot paid a lot more um
uh uh uh than you do now
why does this matter for people worker
behavior well
there's a negative externality now on me
working really hard what's an
externality essentially like an effect
on you
[Music]
that you're not really compensated for
that as i say if i worked really hard am
i really good at my work
not only am i getting paid more but also
you're going to be paid less
right because you know essentially
relatively you're going to look worse
than me if you work in the same team so
relative pay essentially has this issue
about or
matters for social preferences because
essentially any increase in my pay comes
at a like reduction of
your pay to be clear the relative pay is
such that there's an average pay which
depends on the average productivity of
everybody
and then the relative pay sort of on top
of that is like the workers who work
uh more like more productive relative to
others are paid more
um than others okay so what um
um and so how do you think about this
you can think about like a model of pure
altruism we talked about this already
before
there's like a self as a payoff of x
the other person has a payoff of x0 um
for other the self assigns weight alpha
to the other person's utility
this is sort of the typical sort of
model that's been used by becker and
others
we don't really think that's really the
right model for many situations but it's
a really useful benchmark
model and so now if i have like positive
weight on this other person
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
like
in the relative pace scheme i might sort
of not work particularly hard
because i know if i'm working really
hard i'm gonna i'm gonna damage i'm
gonna make you
um worse off does this make sense
okay so i'm gonna um so
show you essentially the briefly the
experiment the impact
the impact of social preference in the
workplace so what they do is they have
like really nice data
on um from the uk from
sorry the microphone from the okay on
fruit pickers under different
compensation schemes they have a
quasi-field experiment they have eight
weeks
in a 2002 picking season where fruit
pickers are compensated on a relative
performance scheme that is to say
the per fruit piece rate is decreasing
in the average productivity
so your incentive is to keep the
productivity low if you care about
others essentially
the more you produce the more you get
yourself but the other person
uh everybody else gets less so
essentially now you have an incentive
to not work too hard because you work
too hard other people around you are
going to be paid
less in the next two eight weeks however
the compensation switched to like a flat
piece rate per fruit
and so now the externality is shut down
however it doesn't really matter for you
it doesn't matter how much i produce
you essentially just um
get however much you produce or like the
payment for that
um the switch was announced on the day
when that change took place so it's kind
of like as a surprise to workers so
workers were working
for eight weeks and then uh for another
eight weeks there was a switch and they
didn't know that this change was going
to happen this is a surprise change
so we shouldn't see any anticipatory
effects of that
now the relative effects now of this
policy depends
now on this alpha term if i don't care
about others at all it shouldn't matter
i should just work really hard as hard
as i can
because i want to increase my relative
pay however if my alpha is high
i might sort of work not so hard because
i'm worried about essentially my friends
or
co-workers being paid less and here's
what they find essentially find a
dramatic increase in productivity
so on the left-hand side you see
essentially the first eight weeks
which essentially is like you know their
productivity this is like
kilograms per hour of fruit that are
being collected
that goes up dramatically in the second
half you see
on the left side you essentially see no
pre-trend it doesn't look like people
are getting just more productive over
time maybe because they become more
experienced or they don't know how to
understand better how to work fast
it seems really flat on the left-hand
side on the right-hand side it goes up
by quite a bit
pretty much very quickly after this
policy is
announced it doesn't seem there's any
other significant changes it really
seems like
worker productivity per hour goes up for
example the number of workers in the
same field
stay the same and so on it doesn't seem
to be lots of other effects
really the main thing that seems to
happen is that worker's productivity um
goes up
is this changes is this response to
changes in the piece rate
now in fact the piece rate went down
like how much you were
rewarded for the marginal kilogram that
you collected
actually went down uh in fact there were
like incentives to work
less if you only cared about your own
output that's also this is robust to
controlling
so now what's going on here well it
seems to be um uh
uh so it seems to be that workers care
about others
uh but not only do they care about
others um it also seems to be that the
effects are
larger the more friends somebody had on
the field so some workers have lots of
friends on the field in the same field
that are sort of their comparison group
and others did not now why does it
matter how many friends you have in your
field if you care
presumably you care more about your
friends than other people so now um
you might sort of have social
preferences you work less to help others
because if you work not very much
they're going to be paid more and you
might care about them so
you work even less when the friends
benefit because you care more about your
friends than others
so then you should see stronger effects
if you have more
friends on the field of the piece rates
versus the other
effects the second part is it's also
like a repeated game and that's kind of
a trickier to deal with which is your
friends might sort of punish you in
various ways if i work really hard
they can see i'm working really hard you
know uh they might sort of punish you
socially at night or they might sort of
be mean
they might just not want to be your
friends anymore and so on it's really
the mean thing to do to your friends
so if you do that um
you know you might actually not want to
work hard just not because you care that
much about the others but you're worried
about essentially retribution you're
worried about them sort of punishing you
if you are uh working too hard too fast
now what kind of variation could we look
at to just disentangle those
type two types of effects so they have
different types of fruit i can tell you
already but like what kind of variation
would we need to disentangle those two
explanations
or let me ask differently what's crucial
in part number two for that explanation
so i'll give you another hint there's
like raspberries and strawberries
for strawberries you can see very well
what the other person does for
raspberries um
you cannot and why does that matter
because like then your friends won't
know and like you just do them
exactly like if you are um uh
if your friends don't know well if it's
explanation number one you really care
about your friends it doesn't matter
what your friends know or not
uh how much you produce you care about
them a lot
you're not going to work particularly
hard because working really hard
is bad for your friends if instead
you're worried about retribution
well then it matters a lot whether your
friend can see what you do
if you do the strawberries which answer
is on the field you can see really
easily
what you do if that's the case um you're
going to depress your effort in the
relative pay scheme
however if you are and that doesn't
really um
and then there's going to be a large uh
a large effect when you have once you
have your individual pay
right however if you are if you can hide
what you're doing
uh then in some sense you might work
secretly really hard in some of the
bushes
um your friends will never be able to
tell whether you would be working hard
and then you should see less of an
effect when the switch happens
and this is exactly that productivity is
observed for the strawberries it's
unobserved to raspberries
and so what we see is essentially has no
impact of the piece rate for
our food type number two which
essentially is to say if you can sort of
hide from your friends you will
you will in fact work really hard which
is essentially
suggestive that like you don't care that
much about your friend instead what you
care about is social sanctions or some
form of like punishment
which only happens for uh the
strawberries because that's when people
can actually see
what you produce okay um i can maybe
briefly recap this next time let me sort
of just
stop here next lecture uh i'm gonna
show you a lot more um uh field evidence
uh from various settings essentially uh
the paper by
uh brazil that have morale effects and
so on essentially looking at in field
situations uh
i'm going to show you that social
preferences seem to matter quite a bit
and then in particular we're going to
look at the malleability of
pro-sociality
which is the question of like well
should we take social preferences as
given
or are there some interventions or some
policies that perhaps could make people
become nicer or more pro-social in some
situations is there something that the
government or like
companies or so could do to
get workers or people to be more
pro-social
that's all for now thanks so much